[Alkış]
Ee ülkenin nasıl borçlanacağından
hayatınızı etkileyen regülasyonlara
kadar artık birçok alanı ilgilendirir
bana etkisi nedir derseniz işte
cebinizdeki paranın değerini Niye ne
kadar vergi ödeyeceğinizi hangi meslekte
çalışacağınızı Hatta evinizin nerede
kuracağınızdan emeklilikte ne kadarlık
bir harcama yapabileceğinize kadar
doğumdan ölüme kadar Aslında hayatınızı
her alanda ilgilendiren bir süreçtir ben
de buna Aslında üniversite hayatında
farkında varmış oldum ve bundan yaklaşık
işte 20 yıl önce Türkiye'nin yaşamış
olduğu en derin ekonomik krizlerden
birisinde farkında varmış oldum 2001
ekonomik krizi Ama tabii ki ekonomik
krizler bir anda oluşmuyor ekonomik
krizleri Aslında arka tarafta halının
altına İtilen süpürülen bir çok sorunlar
biriktiriyor biriktiriyor ve krizleri
Aslında arka tarafta oluşturan bir ortam
dünyaya gelmiş oluyor Örnek vermek
gerekirse işte elinizi bir balon
şişiriyorsunuz şiş biliyorsunuz
şişiriyorsunuz balon şişiyor şişiyor
şişiyor ve of bir anda bir olayla
beraber patlayıveriyor Türkiye'de de bu
olayın patlayan en önemli konulardan
birisi Gerçi buradaki salondaki herkesin
yaşı uygun mudur bilemiyorum ama 21
Şubat 2001 tarihine karı Çarşamba diye
geçen gün ne oldu işte o gün hükümetin
yetkilileriyle Cumhurbaşkanı arasında
bir toplandı gerçekleşti çok gerilimli
bir toplantıydı ve medyaya yansıyan
başlıklarla beraber Cumhurbaşkanı
başbakanı anayasa doğru itti fırlattı
Başbakan hızlı hışımlı bir şekilde çıktı
bir basın toplantısı yaptı ve dedi ki bu
bir Siyasi kriz ve o Siyasi kriz
söyleminin ardından da işte bizim 21
Şubat dediğimiz Türkiye'nin en derin
ekonomik ve Finansal krizlerinden birisi
yaşandı bir gecede gecelik faizleri
yüzde 7.500 arttı yani ne demek bugün
bankada olan 100 liranız ertesi gün 7
600 lira oldu yine aynı gecede kur %50
değer kaybetti yine Örnek vermek
gerekirse bugün Dolar Euro paritesi
18-19-40 civarında ya işte bunun ertesi
gün kalkıyorsunuz ve bir anda 38 lira
olduğunu görüyorsunuz tabi Ne oldu
Türkiye'de o zaman faaliyet gösteren
yaklaşık 50 bankanın 20'si battı ve
Türkiye en derin ekonomik krizlerinden
sonra yaklaşık %60 ekonomik daralma ile
beraber Aslında en derin ekonomik
krizlerinden birisini yaşamış oldum Tabi
o süreç benim için olağanüstü bir
süreçti Çünkü sürekli basında işte
olanlar bitenler Bu arada %6 ekonomik
daralma da herkesin gelir 100 liradan 94
liraya düştü demek değil kimilerinin
şirketi battı Kimileri işini kaybetti
Yani aslında ekonomideki bir kısım bölüm
çok daha fazla etkilendim Tabii dediğim
gibi o zamanlar ben üniversitede işletme
bölümü öğrencisiyim ama haberlerde
sürekli ekonomik Buhran ve ekonomik
buhrandan sonra ne var şimdi örnek
vermek gerekirse o zaman hükümet
demiştim ya işte o zamanki dönem
başbakanı Ecevit ve Anavatan Partisi ana
marifet Partisi Yılmaz hemen yan tarafta
da siyasi Türkiye siyasi tarihinin
vazgeçilmez
hükümet ortaklarından Devlet Bahçeli
Bunlar 20 yıl önce yine bir ekonomik bu
Fransa sahnesinde Ben Bilkent
Üniversitesi öğrencilerime Ders verirken
de aslında benim Kariyerim nasıl
şekillendiğini hep onlara da yönelik bir
şekilde anlatıyorum işte tekrardan Kara
koalisyon ardından İMF ve karloku ile
Türkiye'ye gelen bir kurtarıcı işte
Türkiye'nin ekonomisi yeniden
şekerlenecek o zaman 19 milyar dolarlık
IMF ile bir stand var imzaladık ve o
zamanki 19 milyar dolardı 2001 yılında
Türkiye'nin milli gelirini yaklaşık
%10'u kadar Bayağı büyük bir rakama
tekabül ediyor ve ondan sonra aslında
benim de kendi kariyer değişiklikle
ilgili neler oluyor neler bitiyor
anlamak öğrenmek isteğiyle beraber hele
şu ilk önce Amerika'da doktora Ondan
sonra da ilk İş tecrübesi de IMF olarak
sürece başladım benim evime ilk İşe
başladığım yıllar küresel senkronize
olarak dünya ekonomisini çok iyi gittiği
yıllar işte 2006-2007 her şey o kadar
iyi ki
IMF'nin tek borç verdiği
sonra da 2012 yılında vereceğini
Türkiye'ye yaptım 2000'li yıllar Tabii
Türkiye'nin Aslında küreselle beraber
senkronize olarak çok iyi gittiği
yıllardı birçok açıdan Türkiye gerekli
yapısal reformlarla beraber evdeki
sorunların Büyük bir kısmı düzeltti işte
Örneğin bankacılık sistemi ya da Kamu
Maliyesi Yine benzer şekilde Aslında
Türkiye'nin yüksek oranda büyüdüğü
istihdamın arttığı Eğitim sağlık gibi
birçok indikatörde de aslında hızlı
kazanımlar elde ettiği bir yıldı ama
bilmiyorum Tabii ben bir sebep oldum ama
2010 yıllar maalesef Türkiye'nin küresel
evime kaybı oldu ve biraz şöyle oldu Az
gittik uz gittik dere tepe düz gittik ve
döndük baktık ki aynı yere geri geldik
şimdi benim size burada gösterdiğim İyi
ki Türkiye'nin yolkusulukla yolsuzlukla
mücadele konusundaki çetelesi ne
görüyoruz burada işte Yüzdelik dilimler
yüzdelik dilimde %100 ne kadar
yakınsanız Dünya Bankası istatistikler
içerisinde yaklaşık 200 banka içerisinde
o kadar iyi bir konudasınız demek geriye
düştükçe sıfır düştükçe de son
gruptasınız anlamına geliyor Biz
yolsuzlukla mücadelede
2002'deki seviyemiz oldukça düşükmüş en
düşük %35'lik dilimdeymişiz sonra
2011'de
yükselmişiz 159'a kadar yükselmişiz ama
sonra geri gelmişiz 2021'de tekrar %40'a
gerilemişiz Hukukun üstünlüğü Tabi en
çok kanayan yaralardan birisi Burada da
yine
2010'lı yıllardan sonraki kurumsal ivme
kaybıyla beraber 2021'de en düşük
%37'lik birime gerilemişiz katılımcılık
ve hesap verilebilirlik Bu da tabii ki
En çok eleştirilen konulardan birisi
burada durum daha da kötü Burada da
yaklaşık 200 ülke arasında en düşük
%24'lük dilimdeyiz
Şimdi bana dönüyorlar diyorlar ki
2010'larda Türkiye büyümedi mi Tabii ki
büyüdü Ama biz ekonomi yapıcıların artık
önemsediği konu büyüme değil aslında
Kalkınma kalkma büyümeden çok daha
kapsayıcı bir şey şemsiyedir ayaklarını
şöyle düşünebiliriz bir ayakta büyüme
vardır bir ayakta sürdürülebillik vardır
bir ayakta yaşam standartları vardır bir
ayakta yine iklim değişikliklerine
mücadele ve çevreye saygı vardır yani
çok daha kapsayıcıdır Oysa ki büyüme
Ardışık 2 yıl içerisinde toplum
genelinde gelirin ne kadar arttığına
bakar Şimdi ben size yine bir örnek daha
vermek istiyorum Bu örnekte de bizim hep
rol model aldığımız işte fırsatlar
ülkesi olarak nitelendirilen Amerika'dan
örnek vermek istiyorum
burada ilk önce Amerika'daki kişi başına
milli gelirdeki artışı görüyorsunuz işte
onlar yıllık dönemler içerisinde
Amerika'daki kişi başı gelir ortalama
%30'lar civarında artmış Tabii 2000'li
yıllar 2010'li yıllara göre daha iyiymiş
ama hani bakarsak bu niye tekabül ediyor
yıllık ortalama %3 civarında bir gelir
artışı ortalama Bu da işte enflasyondan
birazcık daha iyice bir gelir artışı
olmuş Amerikan ekonomisi için yani şöyle
bakınca Aslında fena değil
diyebilirsiniz ama 2010'lı yıllarda
Aslında ekonomik büyümeyi tetikleyen
temel unsur bildiğiniz üzere teknoloji
firmaları oldu şimdi ben size burada
Amerika'nın büyük teknoloji
firmalarından birisi olan Microsoft'un
piyasa pay değerini gösteriyorum
Microsoft'un piyasa pay değeri Son 20
yıl içerisinde yaklaşık
%660 artmış yani Ortalama bir Amerikan
halkının kazandığının yaklaşık 22 katı
daha yüksek bir kazanç Bu da bize ne
çıkardı 2010'lı yıllarda aslında evet
büyüme var gelişme var ama bu kapsayıcı
değil Toplumun geneli Aslında
Enflasyonun altında yaşam
standartlarında bir dejenerasyona
uğrarken Sadece küçük bir kesim çok
kazanmış tabi bunlarda işte özellikle
demokrasiler artık Bitiyor mu işte çok
daha fazla Radikal toplumdaki
ilerlemeler daha da mı gidecek mi gibi
süreçleri bizim hayatımıza getiriyor ki
bunun en büyük yansımalarından birisi de
gelir adaleti konusunda biliyorsunuz
yine burada Amerika'dan Örnek vermek
gerekirse Amerika gelişmiş ülkeler
arasında gelir adaletsizliğinin en
yüksek olduğu 5 ülke o S7 ülkeler
içerisinde de yani Gelişmekte olan
ülkeler arasında da bu da ne demek
oluyor demek ki Amerika'dan daha kötü
bazı ülkelerde var kimler vardır deseniz
3 sırada Türkiye var ki Türkiye'nin bu
2019 yılı verileri biliyorsunuz 2019'dan
sonra özellikle işte uygulanan düşük
faiz ve yüksek büyüme hedefleriyle
beraber elimize ne geldi vasat büyüme
Çok yüksek bir enflasyon ve çok yüksek
bir diş Ticaret açığı yüksek Enflasyonun
da aslında en temel kayıplarından biri
nedir orta gelir ve düşük gelirin ciddi
derecede yoksullaşması ve bir
adaletsizin daha da artması anlamına
gelir yani Muhtemelen Biz 2021-2022 yılı
verilerine baktığımızda meksika'yı
arkanıza bırakacağız birinci sırada olan
Kosta ile de farkı oldukça kapatmış
olacağız
Ama tabi benim burada gelmek istediğim
sorun bu değil Evet sorunlar var küresel
çerçevede işte artan jeopolitik
gerginlikler küresel iklim krizi işte
Türkiye'nin şu anda üzerinde bulundurmuş
olduğu birçok ekonomik sorun ve
kurumsallıktaki Eksen kaybı Evet bunlar
çok büyük sorunlar ama ben size şuradan
örnek vermek istiyorum
Bu arkadaşlar Çince kız kelimesinin
yazılması anlamına geliyormuş iki tane
karakter kullanıyorlar karakterlerden
bir tanesi tehlike diğeri de fırsat
anlamına geliyor yani kriz durumları da
şu anda gerek küresel ekonominin gerekse
Türkiye ekonomisinin bulunduğu bir kriz
ortamında aslında evet tehditler var
Belki biz hep tehdit ortamlarına bakarak
kendimizi Belki daha olumsuz
hissediyoruz ama önümüzde birçok fırsat
da var şimdi Türkiye açısından bakacak
olursak aslında kapsayıcı bir yönetim ve
doğru politikaların uygulanması ile
beraber çok hızlı yeniden büyüme ve
kalkınma sürecine girmenin imkanı var
Biz bunu 2000'li yıllarda öğrendik kendi
Hatalarımızı yaptık 2020 yıllarda bunu
çok daha iyi yapabiliriz Önemli olan
bunu tabii ki Toplumsal olarak
benimsemek ve bunu destekleyecek
süreçleri yerine koymak ekonomi
açısından Bence konu çok daha kolay
Sürdürülebilir Çünkü Türkiye'nin
gerçekten nitelikli bu işi bilen çok iyi
bir beşeri sermayesi var yine benzer
şekilde bu beşeri sermaye Türkiye'nin
genç nüfusu yine 2020'li yıllarda
Türkiye'deki inovatif alanlarda yüksek
büyümeye ve kapsayıcı büyümeye
destekleyecek en önemli unsurlardan
birisi olacak Diğer tarafta Bence
Türkiye'nin en önemli
elindeki varlıklardan birisi de iş
gücünün yapısı gerek iş gücünün birçok
alanda tecrübeye sahip olması uzmanı
gerekse Aslında kendisini çok kolay
adapte etme yeteneği ile beraber Aslında
Türkiye büyüme ve kalkın potansiyelini
elinde barındıran çok önemli bir fırsata
sahip bir de tabii ki şu andaki beşeri
coğrafi ve kültürel konumumuzda
Türkiye'yi daha da destekleyen süreçler
örnek vermem gerekirse 2010'lı yıllarda
Dünya Bankası'nın en büyük
paydaşlarından birisi olan uluslararası
Finans kurumunun Türkiye'de merkezin
taşıma projesi vardı yine Dünya
Bankası'nın merkezlerinden birisine
İstanbul yapma projesi bu Bunlar
tekrardan gelmesi için çok büyük
fırsatlar Bir de tabii ki ne var yani Şu
aşamada Aslında belki bir Bektaşi
fıkrasıyla söylemem gerekiyor ama
bektaşinin önünde iki testi şerbet
koymuşlar Demişler ki işte hani sen
karar ver Hangisi daha güzelse onu
alalım diye bir zevkli almış iki tane
testiyi böyle bir içmiş hemen diğeri
demiş Neden Demişler bu o kadar kötü ki
diğeri kesin daha iyidir demiş
şimdi Türkiye'nin durumu da biraz
Aslında böyle dışarıdan Aslında bize
yatırımda bulunmak isteyen gerek
finansal sektör yatırımcıları gerekse
Özel sektör yatırımcıları Aslında
Türkiye'den bir umut işareti bekliyorlar
o işaretini gördükten sonra da aslında
bizim 2000'li yıllardaki gibi çok yüksek
miktarda fiziki ve nakit sermaye
girişini almamız olası şimdi küresel
tarafa bakacak olursak da evet Hani
küreselde de aslında olumsuzluklar var
ama olumlu destekleyecek ve çok Aslında
pozitif girdi de var nedir bir
teknolojik veren ve her ne kadar işte
insanlar işsiz kalacak işte
artacak gibi karamsar senaryolar da
varsa aslında teknolojik giyme
insanların Hayat standartlarını çok daha
iyileştirecek gelir Adaletine çok daha
yaygın ve tavana yayılmış bir şekilde
geçirebilecek bir fırsat sunuyor ki yani
bakacak olursak Aslında insanoğlunun
Hayat Stan 1900'lü yıllardan beri her
sürekli giderek arttı Yani şu anda Her
birimizin yaşam standardı Muhtemelen
1800 yıllardaki bir aristokratın yaşam
standlarından çok daha iyi işte doğumda
beklenen ölüm yaşı gibi birçok
istatistikler çok daha iyi yine tıptaki
küresel koordinasyon da kesinlikle ya
bana atılmamalı dünyanın bir araya gelip
sorunlarına çözüm bulabilme kapasitesi
var biz bu kapasiteye gerek ikinci dünya
savaşından sonra kürlerinden yeniden
canlanan bir dünyaya ekonomisine gördük
gerekse çok yakın zaman da dünyanın
başbaşa kaldığı kovid pandemisinden
sonra hızla hayatınıza gelen aşılamalar
küresel aşı takvimiyle beraber de
yaşadık yani Şu aşamada çok da geriye
gitmeyeceğiz 2 yıl öncesinde bizim böyle
bir konferansta bir yere gelme imkanımız
yoktu ama bugün Biz bunu başarabildik ve
yaptık Yine benzer şekilde küresel iklim
değişikliği bir taraftan İnsanların
hayatına Eee Tabii ki büyük
tedirginlikler katarken Diğer tarafta da
aslında işte karbon yutan makineler çöp
toplayan denizin dibindeki işte
makineler işte uzaktan çalışma
imkanlarıyla beraber Aslında emisyon
salgınımızı düşürten modeller işte
doğaya karışabilen kıyafetler
aksesuarlar gibi Aslında belki de bizim
gerçekten de kolektif bir şekilde
2020'li yıllarda Hayat standartlarımızı
iyileştiren ve dünya ile daha barışık
bir modele girme imkanımız var diye
düşünüyorum
özetle bunları Aslında küresel çerçevede
yapabildiğimizin resimleri var Kendi
Türkiye tarihinize bakacak olursak da
Birinci Dünya Savaşı'ndan sonra tamamen
harap olmuş ve çok büyük bir yükün
altına giren yeni bir Türkiye
Cumhuriyeti doğduysa 2020'li yıllardan
sonra biz bunu başarma kapasitesine çok
daha sahibi Unutmayalım ki Umut
bulaşıcıdır ve Umarım 2020 yıllarda
hayatımıza umut dolu ve daha güzel
günleri açan bir sayfa olarak ayak
izlerimizi bırakırız beni dinlediğiniz
için teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]